the tomorrow war is a topsy-turvy time
travel adventure starring chris pratt
fighting aliens
from the fate of its heroes to the
future of mankind here's the ending of
the tomorrow war explained
when we meet him dan forrester is
obsessed with becoming the scientist
he'd always hoped to be
making his family proud in the process
when that plan doesn't work out then
begins to spiral
he eventually learns that this
insecurity over his past splinters his
family
before his own death in an accident in
2030. for dan the future he made for
himself the one that began the night he
was told he didn't get his dream job
was a bleak one you just never
you never seemed happy with your life
but fighting in the future war returning
safely and defeating the white spikes
before they could spread
seems to have turned dan's outlook
around if not his whole life
the movie doesn't tell us exactly what
his future holds we have no idea if he's
able to parlay his heroics into getting
his dream job after all
or even if he manages to survive past
2030 in the new future he's helped to
carve out
but the good news for dan is that he's
finally found the real purpose
and meaning in his life thanks to losing
his daughter in the future
for however much time he has left dan is
focused on his family and that seems to
be enough
though he jumps into the future and then
back into the present dan forrester's
tomorrow war story is actually fairly
straightforward
the same cannot be said for his daughter
miori forrester who grows up to become a
respected and tireless military research
scientist
and ends up working with her dad in an
effort to save the world
we follow dan for the whole film but we
see miuri in fragments
and her ultimate fate in the film means
her future is rather
complicated we know that during her
childhood myori was very
interested in science so it makes sense
that she grew into a key researcher
in the fight for humanity's future but
by the end of the tomorrow war
future miori isn't just dead the future
she was a part of has been changed by
her father's heroism
the last time we see her in the film
it's as a child still full of hope and
promise
as with dan we don't know if miyori's
future still holds these things
the film doesn't tell us what she grows
up to be after the future war is wiped
away
the tomorrow war ends with the future
everyone is accepted being wiped away
leaving plenty of unanswered questions
for our heroes and for the world at
large
many of these unanswered questions are
positive things leaving open endless
possibilities now that humanity is no
longer going to be wiped out in 30 years
by an alien horde but one
question might linger over at least one
character like a terrifying eventuality
when he meets the future version of his
daughter dan learns that he and his wife
emmy eventually divorce
in part because of his own personal
insecurities throughout the 2020s
when he arrives back in the present
recommitted to his family dan seems
resolved to keep that from happening by
being a devoted father
and husband but can he ever really know
that he'll prevent it
what if he and emmy are just destined to
have a finite marriage what if some
other disappointment comes along to make
him spiral again
dan can work as hard at being a husband
and father as he wants but some things
might be inevitable
or not early in the tomorrow war we see
emmy forrester using her own skills and
expertise to help in the war effort
serving as a trauma counselor for
veterans who have returned from their
seven day tour of duty
in the future though they survive their
fight with the white spikes many of
these people are missing limbs
and the psychological damage runs even
deeper it's a major mental health crisis
amid the larger crisis of the battle for
the future by the end of the film the
fight for the future is seemingly over
but that doesn't change the experiences
of the veterans who made it back to
their present
the battle is over and for those in the
future it never even happened but for
the soldiers who survived the scars will
remain forever
in a world eager to move on from crisis
will those veterans be taken care of
hopefully people like emmy will keep
fighting for them because their wounds
didn't vanish when the white spikes did
early on in the tomorrow war as the
human race of the present is just
learning to comprehend the future threat
and the time travel system that warned
them about it
dan and his new friend charlie make a
discovery all the soldiers who have been
sent back to train them for future
battles are quite young
so young that they haven't been born yet
when the film kicks off presumably to
avoid some kind of paradox in which they
run into their past selves
it's the same reason why soldiers from
the president who are sent to the future
are all people who will be dead by 2051.
it just keeps things easier
why don't we just jump back to earlier
in the war the jump link doesn't work
that way
this system makes sense but as a film
ends it leaves a few lingering questions
particularly since the time travel
mechanism in the future is destroyed
what happens to those future soldiers
since the future has presumably been
changed by destroying the white spikes
it's possible they were never born at
all so do they just
vanish it's one of the most fascinating
wrinkles in the film's world building
late in the film after he returns to the
present and finds himself cut off from
the future
dan goes looking for the origins of the
white spikes in the hopes of preventing
the future war from ever happening
with help from charlie and one of his
brightest students he realizes that the
white spikes went undetected not because
they were stealthy but because they
actually landed on earth
centuries in the past in fact they were
frozen in russian glaciers for 1 000
years
until the ice finally thought out and
freed them in the late
2040s this means that climate change and
the continued thawing of polar ice
around the globe contributed to the
awakening of the white spikes and helped
cause the invasion
humanity didn't know it but by failing
to address the arctic melting they
sealed their own fate
this development is essentially
presented as a throwaway explanation in
the overall plot but it leaves a human
race with some major future wisdom that
they perhaps didn't have before
the white spikes may be gone but the ice
is still melting and that creates future
danger of a very different kind
word of the future war arrives quickly
without warning and with a lot of
catching up to do on the part of
humanity in the present day
one day everyone's enjoying a soccer
match and the next the whole world has
to prepare for a war
30 years in the future in the universe
of the tomorrow war we learn that once
proof of the future threat is
established the world's governments leap
into action
countries band together uniting against
the common enemy on a scale never before
seen in human history
and institute a global draft to ensure
there are enough soldiers to battle the
white spikes
it's a massive effort but what happens
when the future war ends
as the film closes a human race is
celebrating the end of the white spike
threat
but they're also facing other issues the
present has endured massive loss of life
from the war
and there's also the ongoing collective
trauma of the survivors
families are shattered incomes lost
entire communities ravaged
it's a good time for the world to remain
united even though the larger threat is
gone
the question is will they the white
spikes the menacing aliens that dominate
the tomorrow war are set up a seemingly
perfect predators
they're heavily armored fast strong and
they even have offensive weapons in the
forms of the spikes they shoot from
their limps they spread across
continents in a matter of months
overrunning the world through a
combination of aggression and a strong
reproductive cycle
they do all this after sitting in stasis
under ice for a millennium
and just one small colony manages to
reproduce and conquer an entire planet
so even though that colony has been
wiped out the governments of the world
have to be wondering
where did the white spikes come from and
how do we stop them from trying to take
over the planet again
are they on other planets in our solar
system is there a chance we could
encounter them again
could more colonies still be in stasis
somewhere in the world there are a lot
of lingering questions about these
fierce predators
and the world needs answers when dad and
his team arrive at the white spikes
crash sites near the end of the film
they discover a crashed spaceship but it
doesn't belong to the spikes
no those fierce aliens were actually
cargo the ship itself was piloted by a
pair of more humanoid-looking aliens who
have since
died but they were very clearly in
charge of the ship sadly because they
have to blow the whole vessel up to stop
the white spikes dan and company don't
get to preserve these alien bodies
but their very existence poses a number
of questions how did they crash 1000
years ago was earth their target or did
they end up here accidentally were they
using the white spikes as weapons or
were they for something else
are there more of them out there already
on the way to our planet whatever they
are more than one alien species poses a
potential threat by the end of the
tomorrow war and they might just be
biding their time
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one